[Music]
on that note are we start are we rolling
oh hey we might be drunk folks welcome
how the hell are you we got uh we got
yamanika Saunders here our old pal
fellow comedian yes she just woke up
from a Cosby
I didn't wake up from a nap oh man you
came for straight from the gym I came
straight from the gym I did some extra
steps today I walked to like back on the
subway back in poverty time
back on the subway with the poor people
Uber has really Uber's a rich man's game
a consistent yeah rich man you can't be
on Hiatus from nothing if you want to
stay on Uber but we got whatever we're
going after this we got your Uber you
really do of course yeah [__] I ain't
got nowhere to go I'm walking up to my
um psychiatrist even better
you guys are so cute I should have known
y'all had the Uber hookup oh yeah we got
the app
yeah we got the hook up yeah you worried
about the Subway at all like that seems
like the slashings went up yeah I mean I
haven't for
two and a half years I didn't go in the
Subway at all whenever the pandemic
start to whatever it kind of like died
down a little bit then you know
um I'm not I don't want to be I don't
like being around people in general so
you know what I mean you didn't already
added murder to the [__] too you didn't
added murder to some [__] I already
don't want to do like oh I'm really not
gonna be here now right you know it's a
good point it's crazy the DMV it's even
worse yeah it's like it it's a poor
person's game too I hate to talk about
poverty but this is you know I don't
want to die like that no you know people
want to die you know
that means a bad way to die I mean stat
first of all this the thing about
stabbing is this
how slow do you have to be moving to get
stabbed but then also you got to
remember sometimes you can't break away
that's my thing because like if I got
open air it's gonna be hard for you to
stab me if I'm awake right you know what
I'm saying like a foot gotta go out arm
got to go out when you on the subway and
everybody's sitting down and all this
other nonsense the stabbing it can't
happen immediately because you ain't got
nowhere to go yeah but the only thing
they could possibly save you is that the
person Can't Get Enough velocity and
they are because they can't go back but
so far and then it's light standing hard
to stab in rush hour yes no room you
need the yeah the rotation sure yeah
what about one of these you're next to
somebody
you know you hit him with the old uh
you know what I I one of my um one of my
friends said he
know about just tell the story I'm not
gonna say his name he he was in prison
yeah and it wasn't me yeah I wish I you
you never know I wish I had gotten
access to Bill Cosby back in his pill
days because
I would have sued him so hard you know I
I get it you want him just to be
vilified but I also want some cash sure
you know what I mean like you ain't like
you know the statue of limitation is up
but hush money never expires
um my friend he was uh and uh he was in
prison and this you know what cells
might somebody tell you something to
sound like a lie but they tell it to you
so well you like oh is it believable and
then now you gotta go on a deep Google
search to see if it's possible right so
he told me this guy kept messing with
him whatever he's a thin guy he said he
got a piece of paper he was collecting
paper keeping paper hard let to get
crunchy is this a money thing
Millennials y'all don't know about
newspapers oh okay we used to keep the
paper hard what else what a paper I
didn't know what that meant sorry I
don't want to show Mike did y'all think
about newspaper when I instantly said
paper or y'all didn't say I thought
paper was money I gotta make that paper
I can't even mess with y'all I mean I
get it but who even touches paper now
papers obsolete I got paper on me are
you talking about cash yeah you got cash
oh yeah I got a ton of cash I don't have
no cash they said they stopped printing
paper that's what I heard on the
conspiracy theories uh they said no more
paper and then they gonna go to the Yang
or some [__] like that but I don't know
you know I get my news from bet it's a
basketball player
um next thing you know they got the man
said he uh my friend said he went was
crunching the paper making the paper
hard so the paper could be super hard
people gotta be super hard crunchy you
gotta wait I guess months for the paper
to get hard I don't know how long it
takes for people to get hard
because he rolled the paper up he said
he finally got the paper hard he rolled
the paper up got and made a shake out of
it so when the guy came he said he back
with a piece of paper the newspaper I
see and he said the guy was gushing
blood I said gushing off of what I said
was it the obituaries
like to me it was so great crazy that
you could even get paper like that yeah
yeah I had to start googling but I never
found anything to say that was actually
factual I don't know not even a prison
lore toilet paper I mean they get crazy
creative in prison toilet paper knife
can we see that look at that
who made a toilet paper knife I think
the handle's real if you jizz on
anything it'll get hard I mean have you
seen a crunchy sock do you think when
the warden grabs him he's like look this
is terrible but a plus or creativity and
you get a gold star
look at that what are we drinking by the
way what is this oh yeah so it's a hell
of my drink that's like a basil and
um kind of cranberry with a little gin I
want to try that actually I want to try
that can you make me one I'm not
drinking because I stopped drinking but
I definitely when you said all of that I
want that yeah
without I can make it without
the gin yeah I don't don't fart it don't
fall back
honey my addiction ain't alcohol it's
food okay what kind of what kind of food
are we talking what was it oh my god
well first of all at my system I'm I'm
this way because of uh a disability okay
um that hasn't I'm trying to get it up
to Congress oh boy
um when you got a slow metabolism it's a
disability
okay so that's my situation a lot of
people have that problem
um I love macaroni and cheese I love
anything with a crust anything that's
cheesy yep I like anything that's like
um
you you're um you ever had like a um a
fondue right but then you have like a
Cheesy fondue and then you got like a
chocolate white chocolate fondant yeah
yeah my lowest point because I'm not
eating like that anymore because my dad
had diet you've lost a lot of weight I
have lost a lot even though people go
they gotta see a side by side right
because I'm still fat right so like when
fat people start losing weight it's like
well [__] don't stop here you know so
people try to withhold the
congratulations until you you get where
you need to get and then they start to
go oh okay you know all right
so um what was I talking about fondue
yeah that was my ex-girlfriend she was
Asian fond dude
yes let me tell you something mine was
Jewish her name was won't do listen this
is one of the races do
not and baby shark doo doo doo flip it
somebody said that that everything do
rent do pay dude baby shark
y'all need to jump on black Instagram
and Twitter it's more fun oh black
Twitter's amazing and uh uh what is it
Hood Clips oh all of that yeah you can't
I I realized I had to start
um I'm following a lot of white girls
because it was too many pink
organization Amazon
um box reveals for me it's like and they
always got miniature [__] white girls
love little teeny [__] tell me about it
it's a problem
oh man you know where I was going to
relax and enjoy this show because I like
to laugh too yeah that was crazy what
y'all just did that's wonderful and by
the way we would the only reason we
didn't bring a drink out for you I feel
bad now as as host is because I heard
because I heard you don't drink yeah I
don't drink I eat right and I can't you
know what I'm saying I can't do that
like that anymore because you know my
system my metabolism I've had to cut out
so much stuff that I love I love
cilantro number one thing I can't have
really
um so I went and did uh got blood work
done which everybody should do because
you don't know you start following the
things that they say You're supposed to
have and not supposed to have but you
need to follow the things that are
happening for your body thank you so
much my love that looks delicious gut
health yeah all of that so when I went
and got the blood work it said I
couldn't have cilantro there we go oh
cheers thank you to the paper knife hmm
oh that's good you came up with this
yeah
he's a hunk you know we have the paper
plane this is the paper knife there you
go I like that I love it it's good well
said
um yeah Mark I can't take this is what
I'm talking about this is some [__]
you'll never see on the black podcast
she's trying to talk about her journey
to weight loss put food out of his ass
and he know I'm the wrong one to do that
[__] too I would have took a shower to
come here from the gym and you're gonna
shut up
thanks for shooting in my direction
that's crazy as hell and this is exactly
why people be getting murdered on the
train because of [__] like that that's
insane you know all right we're all
adults here insane Mark if you have to
go feel free and you heard I came out
like it was surprised it was surprised
it was you know what it was it was like
it was like a fart the way a guy would
like peek behind a door right
is here but we already being pushed out
I treat everyone equally that's why I
thank you but also I'm offended oh it's
out of love I didn't no I appreciate no
no that's the comfort thing of course it
doesn't smell great either but I can't
talk about food now with this you know
[__] lingering in the damn air that's
crazy you need to go see no no I have to
tell it let me finish it
I went and got blood work done I still
got a couple more they took so much
blood the woman said to me at the lab
she said do you want me to take all this
in one sit down so I was like yeah who
cares of course why would I want to come
back here and get more blood and this
and that right she came out with like 40
little vowels and I said oh okay well
whoa she clearly the [__] Not Gonna
Fill Up all of these right it's gonna be
a drop here drop dead drop drop drop
by the tenth one I was like listen
what so do people be passing out from
this yeah and she's like yeah all the
time yeah all the time that's why I
asked you if you wanted to do a certain
amount I said okay well I said listen
what number do they pass out at because
I just want to beat the person that
passed out and so we wound up doing uh
uh 20 in one day or so I had to come
back and do more of this four more that
I had to do so it's um you know it so it
so it's based upon my body so my blood I
can't have almonds what so you know I
have been making adjustments with almond
milk because they said with Healthy
Living you want to do almond milk
instead of regular milk that was [__]
me up because I can't have almonds it
like it shoots through my system big
time it causes me to withhold and blow
and all kinds of [__] in my system I
can't have peanuts I can't have cashews
I can't have cilantro I can't have green
beans wow I can't have any like I had to
stop Italian food which is really hard
for me because I had I can't have basil
I can't have oregano this is basil in it
doesn't it does it this has just like
the flavor of this there's no actual
what is that green thing yeah you don't
you don't eat it though but oh no
yeah
I just want to see now but I started
bloating up
it's because of the basil but it's a lot
of things that you have to think about
when your system I just been throwing
food in my body because I want it and I
was hungry and I'm eating it I to be
fair to myself I don't eat all the time
I just eat [__] that I just want don't
think about we need to all think about
the things that we put in our mouths
when we eat and four hours ladies don't
think too hard though I mean you know
semen is good for some women in their
diet is it there you go I'm sure
somebody's has a semen benefit yeah yeah
it ain't me I don't think doctors are
giving you that information with your
blood work you should have more semen
a lot of women I'm sure come in with a
lot of semen already yeah and they
probably like continue to do that
because that's actually reducing a lot
of the bacteria and Candia in your
system yes yeah not good for the eyes
though no we've all been there or the
belly of yours is hairy yes you ever
shoot it up on your belly you're like ah
now I got to take a shower it's fun to
make the hot tub though little belly
button I'm never going into a hot sauce
I and not believe you would jerk off on
a hot no no I'm saying the belly button
is like a little hot tub with the jizz
oh boy no I don't know what I wouldn't
do it in a hot tub
and who pulled up 14 things to know
about swallowing semen oh [__] and why
was it bookmarked on your computer man
what are the 14 things we need to know
about following semen please first of
all huh is it is it actually safe to
ingest of course we've all done it for
the most part yes sure it's not the same
as food is it as protein rich as
everyone says oh you can put them in
your shakes
so that's the problem sodium also a
proper chloride problematic too much
calcium problematic damn okay it's
lactic acid come on now it's literally
yeah what the hell is that damn
are you just saying that because it's
it's
urea or what's going on you know that
for sure because I'm this is I said 2023
I'm gonna stop just trusting white men
when they tell me definitions of words
because sometimes it don't even make no
sense like yeah sure because we all
believe a white man right wow I didn't
know but what about uh squirt women
squirt is that
this is not nah I mean no come on ah
yeah let it out sister okay so one time
a guy I was with a guy I did not know
because let me tell you something that
takes a skill it's a guy a specific guy
they can get a woman to do that yep and
then when it happened I was like oh my
God I think I peed on the bed or some
[__] so I was like what is that but then
you know like an idiot
you isn't everybody's first reaction is
to be like put their finger inside them
and go like that sure right yes and I
was like oh that tastes like pee I was
like oh I peed but it is some peas it's
some people
I gotta like it because it it's oh you
got women out here squirting like that
yeah a couple times well I mean my
cousin are very close but
a couple should always be the [__] to
be farting out their ass and get a woman
with a squirt
a very coupled with my body good with
the bad yeah here here but yeah a couple
squirts one time a girl squirted my face
and I got in my mouth oh it did it was
pretty hot because it was like a return
like I know how it felt now you know
what's good for the goose it's good for
the gander wow
I remember many years ago I was in a
comedy condo uh quit bragging and uh and
a woman just squirted everywhere and I
was kind of like Whoever has to clean
this up all right I feel just I just
feel terrible that's that's what it's
the worst was that when you open for
Roseanne
hey she was already on Ambia
what happened to good old Roseanne she
had that one tweet and disappeared I
didn't know the [__] was black I wasn't
bad yeah I used to like rose
we share the same birthday November 3rd
oh there you go yeah so Roseanne shout
out to her but you know what mental
illness is real yeah sure you know and
we all just teetering I know I am tired
no I'm mental illness you just be like
one slip and you're gonna be back right
over there those are the best comics
when they're right on the edge of psycho
yeah yeah she owns a nut farm which is
kind of appropriate but yeah she owns a
nut farm in Hawaii
who Roseanne yeah huh
and she got hit by a car when she was
young and she totally like changed her
personality what is this a
[Laughter]
&e I love comedians yeah I know at your
bio you're from Maryland oh [__] let's
slow it down all right it's already
hitting the right things and I don't
know how much I need out there in the
streets you sure you like that ginger
beer too that's pretty good right I love
this and it you know they said well it's
diet but I don't taste the difference
brewed in Australia let me tell you
something any place that got kangaroos
do not [__] around
how many places
whatever else is in Australia
are there kangaroos over here I don't
think non-zoos well I'd heard Trump
that's a rid of a few an organ they have
kangaroos
I did not know that called a wild kicker
no he's he's [__] around
yeah wild kicker no he's joking so when
they come to America they call them wild
kickers
that's not a bad name so lazy as a
people yeah wild kickers does America
have a secret kangaroo if they don't
they will this is this is Q anon's next
thing they're like the Jews hide the
kangaroos it Rhymes it makes sense yeah
yeah even the kangaroos like what the
[__] am I doing in Detroit look at him
that is a Pixar movie Eddie Murphy does
the kangaroo what the hell am I doing
here he's rapping mom's spaghetti
you ever seen the kangaroo video where
he uh fights the guy that went viral
That's a classic oh I want to see it
really the farmer punches a kangaroo to
the Strangling his dog yes that's the
one when the kangaroo just looks at him
like [__] this guy's got balls of steel
for doing this I mean the kangaroo kicks
his ass well I don't want to ruin it oh
look he [__] with his dog he's choking
his dog so he runs over wait make it
bigger make it bigger wait please wait a
minute how did the dog that's so bloody
oh [__] oh he squared up to him yo he
said yo this is exactly and that's it no
no no no oh the poor dog how [__] up
the dog is oh chopped up I know
oh boy and watch the kangaroo he gets he
that kangaroo is like I'm from Detroit
right no he
he turned his back to him too he was not
scared oh yeah but he looked like he
about to come back
oh man that was my boxing class today
I've been trying to execute that move
but you know what it is you know where
he [__] up you supposed to punch and
then retract immediately that's true
that if he was if the kangaroo was going
to come back wow wide open and get
punched yeah but he was supposed to
punch like this and come back bro and he
could have hit him with a left too and
that kangaroo just sat there and took it
or is this the part in white man's
history when y'all ended because that's
the last punch he got in and then after
that is the kangaroo grilling this
nigga's ass down to the ground cause I
want to see after this why stop right
there the kangaroo they had no response
to that that's a good thing
that must be way he's like yeah that
must be so confusing to punch a kangaroo
yeah you train as a human you're like
you know maybe get in a schoolyard fight
you know how to punch a human you see a
kangaroo I'm like part of me like maybe
you kick it you throw like a little
[__] damn it stood up I know yeah
your initial reaction to a person doing
whatever entity of a car stood up to me
like that I punched that car in the face
because it it's the adrenaline yeah why
are you at my level come on bro yeah it
bucks it's squared up I mean the
pictures of the Jack kangaroo oh they're
hot they're insane oh wow [__]
frightening
him that's adorable eyelashes that's a
joey they call it yeah
yeah yeah they're ripped
oh they fight each other see they
practice but they can stand on their
tails and kick forward what and oh [__]
that's what I mean right in the pouch
damn we need some more kangaroo video
games that's like that's a fun animal to
control
me without a problem Oh my God look at
that [__] and they fighting over a [__]
too
that's how they get down yeah and the
little one looking because he like in a
couple years I'm gonna have to whip this
[__] ass with a woman oh yeah this is
Jerry Springer look at it and do we have
one leg or what's going on with the
other leg he's walking like a 78 year
old Jew I saw on Sixth Avenue hunched
over oh my God you know what I want to
see can you type in little black kids
with raccoon
[Laughter]
dominica's bringing some good Google
leave from me bring it on please yes you
got to do audio too you gotta do all
right you know what go go to the store
because even though it's the short the
short one yeah but turn it up yeah
okay got a kid in the neighborhood with
a raccoon under
her arm
you gotta start from the beginning with
this they gotta hear okay look how she
hold you hold that cool like it's a
newborn baby yeah I'm telling you oh
that's creepy [__] Steve Irwin this
little
a raccoon
look at the raccoon he's scared of the
little girl over there wow
oh wow y'all better be
ready y'all better be careful because if
the mama raccoon said that she gonna
attack y'all
they know where the mama raccoon lives
oh God
they took a blood test holy [__] wait
look at it
that's another one
okay oh my God little girl she did her
own show on the Animal Planet yeah she
have a raccoon
oh my God are you kidding have I ever
tried to touch a raccoon vicious
the second one up they about to have two
records
oh my God
this woman's a pro
this has got to be the South
[Laughter]
[__] like that
I thought they was also in the south
look out of one raccoon I'm blown away
by this
that girl is so in control right he like
help me the raccoon no them kids wow
isn't that crazy yeah they need a cell
phone I never say this about a kid but
give that kid a [__] iPad Jesus
oh my God
kids to be discovered because first of
all they so damn adorable but it's like
they nature I guess I don't think
they'll understand how raccoons get down
because raccoons is cute and [__] right
yeah you'll see a raccoon or one tried
to jump me in Central Park what I'm
telling you they have like little
fingers
and they racist too because the
instantly they hate the white girl yeah
you see they didn't do that to the
little black girl oh
[__] oh no and she got on them La gears
you know they hate L.A gear oh look at
the mama had to get them off
a mom will save any daughter yeah she's
like get in the house [__] I'm trying
to get doing something hitting the house
[__]
a piece of toilet paper stuck to your
foot geez the cleaners
wow that's a great mom
oh [__] that's all she could do oh man
it came back oh no it's a replay yeah
see it's a shame that America's Funniest
Videos is gone because that would have
cleaned up but you know what they would
that would be great on that because they
don't want to see no violence I know
that would have been fun if you do like
four light ones in a row and then out of
nowhere it's just a raccoon eating a
child's face with the sound effects
can you type in let me just go through
my Instagram history oh here we go let's
say this is the yamanika show and merged
in here wait you might be drunk or it
might be you might be yamanika it might
be a red can you type in woman wins
Lottery 43 million dollars and they give
the [__] a steak dinner because they
told her some nonsense that's a long
Google
right well you're supposed to put give
the [__] yeah there you go steak dinner
I gotta go to my save I was just reading
this woman
um this [__] yes is that her I don't
know that's Bobby Lee a lot of things
came up here okay here we go New York
resident wins nearly uh 43 million at a
slot machine and takes home nothing as
Casino claims it was a malfunction
offer steak dinner instead is this it
I think he's talking about it
hey folks it's the new year and you're
probably getting billed for all those
free trials you signed up for in 2022.
you could be wasting hundreds of dollars
each month on subscriptions you don't
even know about that's why we love
rocket money formerly known as true bill
uh rocket money shows all your
subscriptions in one place even the ones
you didn't know you were paying for and
cancels whatever you don't want
you may even find out you've been double
charged holy hell to cancel a
subscription just press cancel and
Rocket money takes care of the rest
get rid of useless subscriptions with
rocket money now go to rocketmoney.com
drunk seriously it could save you a
hundred dollars a year that's
rocketmoney.com drunk cancel your
unnecessary subscriptions right now at
rocketmoney.com
slash drunk
if you're still using your ball trimmer
on your face listen up manscape has
announced their brand new beard hedger
Pro kit the beard hedger is the cordless
trimmer of your dreams and gives you 20
hair cutting lengths from Mr Clean to
Grizzly Adams and everywhere in between
and it's waterproof so you can shave
anywhere once you've done uh some beer
trimming too throw on the manscape beard
shampoo that rhymes and conditioner
designed to moisturize reduce ingrown
hairs hidden ingrown hair yeah that's at
least what I tell them they are on my
junk and replace natural oils and pray
impress your special friends when you
finish off your manscaped beard oil with
beard bomb and since manscape wants you
to have all those tools for the job but
they're throwing in a beard brush comb
and scissors to make you look like a
million bucks 20 off free shipping with
the code drunk
at manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping as well at manscape.com and use
code drunk manscape beard hedger one
stroke one guard 20 lengths nice
you've heard the phrases a hundred times
folks be smart don't start kick the
habit put it out before it puts you out
yet we still continue to have bad habits
fume is on a mission to help break the
bad habits that consumes too many of us
it's not a vape so it's not filled with
the harmful chemicals that come along
with that fume is a natural diffusive
device that uses plants like cinnamon
peppermint to help you trade out your
negative habit for a positive one we
love fume it tastes good it smells good
I keep it in my pocket get a little hit
every now and then the flavors are great
you're gonna love it a lot of different
flavors their new version the version
two is a Snappy and tactile with an
adjustable airflow dial and a magnetic
end cap you always have something to do
with those busy hands
the easiest way to stop a bad habit is
switch to a positive one fume is
designed perfectly just to do that it's
fumes goal to make switching easy and
even enjoyable they have thousands of
five star reviews from people just like
you who've successfully switched when
other Solutions just didn't work there
he is how cool is that
I had to try fume one word
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use code drunk to
save 10 off when you get the journey
pack today the journey pack comes with
three unique flavors and the new version
2 fume to help kick-start your positive
habits that's try fume fum.com and use
code drunk to save an additional 10 off
three million dollar slot machine but
the casino claims there was a
malfunction and she was offered a
stickman instead of what that's [__]
up
okay let's pull
it right there
before I get my take
wait a minute what you going to do what
y'all doing this is illegal they can't
say a malfunction machine
listen listen stop thinking like a white
man okay because they be doing all kinds
of [__] to black people you know that's
how we got here in the first place they
said oh y'all want to cruise somewhere
we say yeah we got here no [__]
Cruise no destination no uh hotty
totties no pina coladas no nothing yeah
but 43 million is way better than a
cruise that was slavery but first of all
y'all said that's unfair right yeah
illegal yes you use a lot of terms that
they not gonna allow her to use because
they gonna try to play this black woman
she can't go to legal right route she
got to go murder somebody over there
like now look how she crying I wouldn't
even be crying 43 for 43 million dollars
I [__] your steak dinner I'm not even
leaving this place yeah I live here now
this is most of my home and so I recoup
43 that's your sitcom by the way I mean
you just living in the city
um and you're always mad at them yeah
it's like the terminal but at the casino
that's good oh it writes itself
every day we'll call it don't slot shame
all right
that's so embarrassing you know what's
so in I remember I was a little kid I've
told this before and I was at Disneyland
it was it Disney which one is a Florida
Disney World World Disney World right
the world's in Florida lives in
California yes as Disney World I said
Disney World
my grandmother kept saying you know how
they had the electric street parade yeah
oh yeah right so after you go see Minnie
and them and Daffy and them you go out
there and have a little parade
my grandma said get involved in the
parade I said I can't they told all the
kids he can't get involved I said I
can't get them all she said no get up
there and she wound up pushing me up
there with Snow White and then
um security
the witch is coming okay hey I was
because I made up of one of the little
trolleys too I was quick with the heave
hoe it's the eighth door Obsessed
the next time I see you in the streets
without cameras you and I are fighting
immediately if you say the eighth dwarf
sassy
I'm gonna warm your ribs up right off
the camera don't raccoon me
yo I hate you so much on site is about
to be on site all right they took me off
the the trolley and I got embarrassed in
front of everybody because and I told my
grandma my grandma said you should I
said I did go up there I said I told you
they said no and then we got some type
of thing where I had to like go just
fill out some paperwork
I wasn't trying to do something to Snow
White or something like that it was an
assassination attempt I'm seven I know
right I might have been a little bit
bigger than that but um how old were you
I probably was like 10. you know so you
don't know yeah you know I got breasts
of like nine and a half so I was like
you know I probably look like a [__]
trying to steal some [__] but
um yeah that was embarrassing that's
about equivocal to this this woman first
of all her name was Bookman
[Laughter]
[__] you better book a hotel room in
there
damn so how did it end I mean she got a
sue you gotta Sue these people
no because there's always some [__] like
I think they just be putting [__] in the
black women's account because it was
another black woman that woke up to like
uh 40 million dollars in her bank
account and they was like oops we put in
the wrong account you got to give it
back oh no [__] Finders Keepers losers
do what figure it out
yeah this is it right here I guess so
what how is it very clear
yeah stop it stop stop stop stop stop
what in the [__] is going on here I
won't say this there are not a lot of
black uh Heist Casino movies that's true
things do seem to Oceans 11 everything
just fits perfectly this is a black
woman and then you know yeah they go
we're so this would be a bad movie all
right well like unfortunately we have to
take it back yes that's it nah they
would kick it in script uh these visuals
going to be shown okay because I need
everybody to get involved in how lazy
this was
it took more time to crop her face to
this portion did it they could have
found something else I just we didn't
need this this isn't a white body there
and when I keep saying Bookman version
like she got some different version of
reality did she lose 43 million dollars
or not when she swindled out of 43
[__] million dollars because that
seemed like that's everybody version
yeah how do they justify this
is
Joe list
[Laughter]
negligence could have caused the
malfunction making them liable for some
compensation
there we go
where the hell is that Queens
Community news our lawyer pause it pause
the pause it when your lawyer look like
this like this heavy ass receding
hairline but he's still got a little bit
of dust in the middle you're gonna win
your case or you're gonna epically lose
it it's no it ain't no like we coming
back it's like he get ready Fail Hard or
you [__] you about to own a casino and
it's about to call me called Bookmans
okay come down to Bookmans all the
machines work
aha
get them
wow
Resorts World
now let's say I go in there and I get I
push a button and it comes up
zero can I go hey
the machine's broken it only is broken
in their favor it's never broken in our
favor right think about how often you go
to like the gym and a machine's out of
order or something or you go to an
arcade out of order yeah this must
happen you don't hear about it but it
must happen but true
three million I'm with you there yeah
that's the problem and they would give
me my phone I wouldn't give a damn if it
was broken I don't care if your
grandmother installed it and she forgot
to put her hearing aids in to balance
off all the bobbles in there I want my
43 million when it said 43 million
dollars that's what it said it's a
casino [__] this ain't no uh fairy tale
land it's a Candy Land this ain't a
[__] come on down about your breast
deal yeah this is a casino
no they put the no in Casino okay right
and but you better call it a casino yes
because I better get my 43 million
dollars or I mean I'm going to tell
everybody The Shred she lost the case so
badly she's now a waitress at the casino
serving station I don't have the money
that's what it's about because if they
was doing what's 43 I would have talked
[__] to them too oh it's 43 million
dollars y'all y'all must be losing them
you mean you ain't got 43 million
dollars laying around here yeah I mean
the casinos they do have that kind of oh
they got money they legally have to be
able to keep cash on deck to pay out any
possible winnings that night hard paper
actually promotions 11. there you go for
12 or so and I want to see the security
cam footage of her getting told no
that's what I want to see I want to see
the back and forth between yes and I
hope it's no words that we got to
interpret it I wanted the earrings
coming off I want to shoe in hand all of
that a thing of Vaseline showing up yeah
ding ding
different mental anguish and
significance
every time every clip of him his hair
get less and less
yeah
nothing's been going on since this [__]
look like this uh we got Robert shible
[Music]
no
it's okay when you win yes that's what
my point
oh stop it stop stop
Stop Printing Cash ticket [__] did you
get a ticket that said 42 million yeah
672.76 because [__] if you got a ticket
that said that
Kaboom yes no Ticky no laundry oh you
better first of all she too calm in that
picture if if I just want 42 being that
my heart I
my lipstick would have been all over the
screen tongue everything I'm telling you
she's too calm like she just be winning
42 million dollars a day all the time
look at me again within 42 million
dollars girl ain't the thing yeah
tickets a ticket if you have that ticket
in your hand that's it it'd be arcades
now for the kids they do away with the
tickets it's on that card ah I don't
like the code oh yeah I don't like that
card either that Carter because it
starts taking money off of you uh-huh
yeah
um this lady said she uh type in 50 no
wait we got to hear the end of this yeah
I need to know how it ended because I'm
worried she got [__] knew that his
client would never win that
interviewers who's going to get the max
payoff that her machine could give here
here
no stop stop stop is it ready he's
already failing yeah let me tell you
something 43 million to 6500 big drop
let me tell you something
any woman who's
who's curved like
like trying to get 65 100 or nothing you
hear me I can guarantee you the words
get right come out of her mouth is I
want my 42 million dollars this clown
told me he could get it for me he said
he was out here suing this one and suing
that one and now I don't even have
enough to get my hair braided at the end
all right now how much does this lawyer
cost I don't know he's in it for the
money he she got to pay him 500 yeah
exactly what about uh yeah what did she
get here I want to see
I hope this would be the least she was
award oh no pause it okay if she caved
you know she didn't say that no that's
why they did a voiceover you know she
did not say well yeah now that woman was
in the camera going does anybody know
another lawyer
but I'm tired of coming in to his office
looking at these raggedy degrees that
couldn't get me my 42 million dollar I
don't understand what what they just be
playing Black people all the time it
Mark said it's illegal yes they would
have immediately gave you 42 million
dollars they gonna go back and forth
with this black woman about 42 million
dollars because she don't have a team of
people behind her that's going to get
this 42 million dollars but she like she
need to do her own oceans 11. oh yeah
get that money back and I hope this hurt
the casino because I'm not going in
there now knowing they got faulty
machines and they're gonna take my mark
they just put in an offer for us to
co-headline I'll be there
let me tell you something all the people
from January 6 said oh we're going to
that casino that's been Robin black
February 6 casino now
[Laughter]
it's in New York City but it's got to be
in deep Queens I assume oh is it is it
the one that's in uh Queens I assume
because it says New York City
it's a New York resident she's a New
York resident but is it I swear I'll
know on the on the side it said give me
a goog on the address there
Maddie I know where we should film The
Next Episode oh yeah the slots I want to
be there and I want to win 42 million
dollars so y'all can get witnessing me
going crazy it's in New York City wow
give me a Queens what is that
oh they definitely ain't got no money
today I knew it nah she better call some
of them Rastafarians out there and get
to work get a bunch of people with
machetes
slicing off dealers hands yeah everybody
call anybody I would get all everybody
together what kind of grid line is this
oh wow you got the street view is that
the street with a casino no wonder they
don't have that kind of money
yeah apparently after 6 500 they went
down to one bacon egg and cheese they
could pay her in the nearby there it is
there it is they didn't even want to
give her the 6500. wow I like that we
have this Google view doesn't it it
feels like we could pull off a heist
when you have all this [__] it
definitely ain't got no money over there
ain't nobody them strip them roads look
like they barely ran yeah that's not a
casino you go to in a good place no does
that say Applebee's on the ground go to
your right
I thought it said Applebee's too oh
Aqueduct oh it's right by the racetrack
so that's out by the airport well
somebody would give me my money it's
either them or the horses somebody every
every time I wouldn't get my money every
day a horse would turn right in the glue
you ever done the horse bets I've done
it I don't how do you better horses the
race they race you know I know you bet
on horses with a race but how can you
tell which one of them ain't stupid they
can that's fast
how can you tell which uh driver ain't
stupid if you I don't know it's it's fun
you could tell which one well with
NASCAR the Dumber they are the better
that they drive because their brains
don't tell them that they got to stop
with these terms and stuff
but the race cars or the racetrack or
the car what the [__] the one that one
of the horses ran off I was in Kentucky
at the keenland uh and one of the horses
just ran off before so they was
qualified so anyone who Bet On It Just
you got your money back how did it
almost run off
he was on it he wasn't on it and the
horse ran off they'd like get him did
they get it yeah oh okay and what
happened to him because you know they'd
be murdering these horses oh yeah yeah
they make glue out of them not a good
life no but that horse demon goes for
top dollar that's true yeah the studs
yeah but the way you gotta get it is you
know I heard it has like less lactic
acid though yeah you don't swallow that
one you just shoot it on your chest okay
oh boy I shoot out of my calf I want to
know what happened
I'm intrigued yeah I guess she didn't
get it
poor lady
so scammers wouldn't try to use it as a
loophole
see him this definitely isn't the first
or the last time
okay it's a honky
equal opportunity scamming here told him
he had won 58 million dollars oh even
more
that sweater vest is a problem
Not only was this payout what is going
on with this place it would have also
been breaking the wall it's a sham yeah
that guy was at the Capitol
he hit it big
Wheels hit the jackpot and she told him
his prize was 463 63 895 unfortunately a
jamming error caused the machine to roll
its wheels back what the [__] the
malfunction made it seemed like Joe won
the jackpot but it only counts if it
were part of the machine's random number
that's horses
verify that kind of [__]
no [__] that I mean that's why that's
why slot machines are [__] because
they're programmed not to let the person
oh no you gotta go cars like like you
play cars you can see what the Dealer's
hand is whatever but if a computer like
it can just tell you to [__] off every
time
I don't play them I play them all the
time I got the the one I don't want to
sound racist because it's not racist but
the little Chinese man with the hat oh
yeah the one you know what you want with
the Chinese man but oh fondue yeah so
not fun dude is it called fondue or
something like that
like I just want to tell the Chinese
Community I'm not being racist but I'm
surprised this slot machine is still
going because he got the little yeah he
looks so damn Chinese in this [__] it's
like who let this [__] still stay and he
got a panda ninja like it's almost like
nobody got on top of this with the
cancer culture right it didn't look like
that I mean we didn't already change
Aunt Jemima into some different [__]
gave her a perm and let her become a
lawyer
what is it now they pulled her off the
shelf and Uncle Ben too
no it's called um what's the name of the
place it's called whatever the company's
called something Bookman I think now
she bought the syrup game what are they
company yeah that's what it's called now
Uncle Ben is out first of all ain't
nobody um eating rice no more oh my God
this is what I tried to get one time I
won so much money on this [__] and then
the thing about this is it gets you you
win in the first it knows when you're
new because I think it reads your
retinas whoa and so when you sit down
within the first about hour if you sit
for an hour you're gonna win at least a
thou okay but then you get the that uh
monkey on your back yeah right yep yep
and then you go chasing it and then
you're gonna wind up being in the hole I
said you don't want three K's in a row
either I mean game for sure but
sometimes it comes up a lot when I'm
sitting there
there it is holy [__] well I don't play
Slots now I'm not done so I'm going
right to the Blackjack yeah I usually
play blackjacks in my game usually I get
embarrassed because I always have to
I'm not good at like you know what I
mean like I'm not a fast math person to
do right in my head so I'm always like
counting and stuff and I and I think
that that's embarrassing right to be
like a grown person going I don't know
six that ain't nothing you know yeah
yeah how many can I but I like that they
give you information
um you can ask them you know like should
I head should I not they'll say oh yeah
they'll give you a little hey you should
hit you shouldn't you know so I like
that today being more generous that's
true helpful but then they kind of know
they got a mark
yeah I mean but they also went they went
with like because different culture
right you tip them out a chip when you
win right yeah so the more you win like
yeah that's true they get some cash from
you too so yeah they I don't think
they're invested I don't think they feel
good when you're drunk at the table like
you're [__] cheating you're [__]
cheating dude I think they're happy when
you're happier probably yeah yeah true
it's always the worst when you're
sitting at that table with some guy
who's like a die hard and you can't make
jokes and he just sneers at you the
whole time old guy sunglasses yeah like
calm down dude exactly I think the poker
table you don't need to [__] psych
anybody out right right we're in Reno
take it easy
Casino guy I don't love them I feel they
make me sad they seem dirty yeah the
rest for old lady on the respirator
who's smoking the guy with the limp the
camo hats it's a bummer you spend too
many days there and you don't see
sunlight and it's like where are you
gonna go go that's the problem when you
do one of those gigs and you're there I
mean remember early on I remember doing
those Arena gigs would be like Tuesday
through Sunday oh yeah am I here for a
[__] week yeah yeah
it's not like you can and people like my
mom be like take a walk I'm like in
downtown Reno right right where you want
to go it's true where do you go they
were ahead of the curve with the meth
stuff they were doing that [__] years
ago oh yeah give give them credit where
credit's due yeah no they were
Progressive Town
drugs you know people on drugs and you
know having all kinds of problems and
stuff the first thing they do is they
try to go somewhere and play the lotto
to get out of their problems or go to a
casino but it's like listen you know you
already being cursed I don't I don't
know why you thought your luck was going
to be at the casino you don't have no
luck you need to go somewhere you need
to go to maybe DeVry and start from
scratch yeah I mean you sit there for
hours and just throw their whole savings
away it's so sad I had a one of my
relatives I can't say which one and if I
just even saying this is too much but
one of my relatives had a bingo
addiction
um and almost lost everything to bingo
so yeah and you know how that was a
funny one it was a funny one to have a
that's an 80s that's an 80s Edition my
nephew lost everything to duck duck
goose it was terrible
awful
parchees
oh man yeah but Bingo was bit was big
back in the day oh yeah in the 80s and
people was losing and they got addicted
to Bingo and it was sad and we had you
know it was a lot of but you know I feel
bad for people when they have addictions
it's sort of out of their control yep um
because if you have an addictive
personality once you get into something
that like like gives you that sensation
of just being alive and all this stuff
you keep trying to chase this thing I
know it becomes a real problem so I I
really think we need to focus more on
trying to rehabilitate people with
addictions instead of like people have
shopping addictions yeah I think people
have addictions to people make fun of
them for and it's like but the
underlying of it all is that there's an
addiction there that is problematic
people do have a shopping addiction and
to all those people I say Bodega
catwhiskey.com yeah we're not feed that
addiction two for the price of one
shopping and alcohol oh yeah here here
yeah booze is our vice it could be worse
out shopping addiction is a tough one
because it's like you
booze at least a bar has got to be open
you know what I mean the internet yeah
you could have alcohol at home but the
internet it's like you could be on the
[__] train you're saying yeah Amazon
you know what I mean it's also that the
computer now is clocking you right and
throwing [__] at you right oh of course
I needed some um OPEC tights I'm a thick
woman
so I gotta go to a thick woman's store
to look for OPEC tights OPEC tights I
went to tour it look for some OPEC
tights
now every time I go to my computer the
Titans everywhere uh
cause I didn't make the purchase now
they're like we gotta hustle this [__]
down until she go make these tights
right and then if I go buy the tights
they gonna offer me something else or
they let me tell you how Alexa is
getting in your business uh oh
I was this was like a month ago unless I
gotta I forget what she said some I have
something to tell you or some [__] like
that or do you want to hear some [__]
about your account or some [__]
something she said and I said yes
she said hey you gotta go get them uh
makeup sponges you you should be running
out of makeup sponges and she was right
now we got sponges I said oh my God so
now Alexis clocking your needs damn too
much you know what's crazy I I did 23 in
May and it gives you you know your
ethnic background but it also it knows
[__] about you that's incredible like
it's like you Pro you you're with your
makeup you would prefer Savory over
sweet and I was like wow that's true
about it is that right one of them was
like body hair and it was like you have
a little bit of body hair at like the
tip of your back and I was like you
[__] nailed it
yeah I'm not doing it I got one called
Paul base for my cats because I want to
see what their makeup is
called Paul base and I I've been toying
with it because I don't know
um once they if they can get my
information from my cast information but
yeah that's a little kit oh that's cute
and you can get in you know so you're
supposed to take it and so it gives you
a whole room this country is great yeah
that's why the terrorism there are
people starving the world we're like I
want to know my catch story well you
know because I also want to know as they
get older what what could be that you
know keep them at a certain sure
whatever things and this and that
so um yeah you know uh look at how cute
he is yawning with his little glasses
and sweater on that's terrifying this is
the cute you know how kind of a great
photographer you got to be to get this
moment that's true or just a sad cat
lady
I did the 23andMe and it just said uh
half gay I was gonna say with the with
the whole like oh I can tell you what
can you tell me your kinks or whatever
oh sure yeah head likes when you tickle
your balls two or three times but four
times is too many I was like wow that's
pretty good
stop me also
somebody was saying we
lady right right sad cat lady and I have
a cat I'm a cat lover oh let me see your
cat oh baby you know I got my two I'll
show you man so now
cat somebody said I'm really the odd man
out on every one of these podcasts Marx
now that Mark's married too it's like
married okay oh my god oh it's a Maine
[__] what yeah it's huge was he at the
wedding
and now that's uh just a picture on our
roof that's a cute that's a cute picture
it's a beautiful cat right there was he
on a leash oh leash he hates outside
he's a big wuss yeah they don't want to
be want to be [__] why
just got a cat shout out to Naima I love
her she's trying to teach this [__] to
go to the bathroom on the toilet and I'm
like come on like you know let the cat
be but anyway it's no sadder person on
Earth than a [__] that owns a pig that
lives in New York City my friend said he
went date with a woman that had a pig
ever and try to embarrass me for having
two cats and saying I'm lonely and
desperate and there's a [__] out here
with a pig in an apartment Pig should
never even be an apartment well you need
to be outside at least if it doesn't go
well you can eat it
she wouldn't you can't eat your cat I'm
just saying if things don't go well yeah
eat your cat but your cats will eat you
so something that's true we uh a long
time ago on this podcast we took a long
time [__] in on people who own ferrets
and I don't think we've ever gotten more
hate really people are like [__] you I
own a ferret oh my God I thought we were
having fun here a lot of people on
Ferris and these Lab Rats they love a
lab rats like rats a lot of rats in the
street in New York right now and I've
never been like you know what I want
that dude inside yeah type in Grandma
prank with rats I want you see these
fools what they did to their grandmother
with the rats oh yeah let me just say
this you should take over for Daniel
Tosh oh yeah you've got so many of these
locked and loaded yeah 1.0
yeah here we go look how he shook the
bread
I would be the same way I don't blame
her yo he shook me what it was french
fries wow anybody in there oh he found
Jemima
anytime you see genuine fear it's comedy
gold that is horrible these are these
kids
oh it's in her hair
is something that's gonna really make
y'all giggle if y'all think this [__] I
mean this is gold dude you're killing it
I mean just the whole Act of shaking it
like it's a bag of chips and just like
you just shake that [__] on your
grandmother some of these kids really
look at her she's doing it one more time
she's holding the containers oh this
poor lady
the reaction is so good that's so good
there's no way that your family should
be doing nothing like that she's gonna
add a massive stroke she might have yeah
you're right
these animals aren't having a great time
either ah good point good point yeah
oh man this is so [__] so funny she
trying to get out with the seat belt uh
oh man first this lady gets [__] in
the slots and now here
this is the uh this is like the epitome
of like this I would be so mad if
someone did this to me but you see it
happening to someone else and it is
[__] great yeah
um
for I'm you know what the next time I
come back I'ma come back locked and
loaded we're just gonna do a hole
because I got a bunch of these we could
be giggling and laughing I'll get an
edible going actually I got a little bit
of something oh baby yeah they helped me
sleep one of them I don't now you gotta
read the packaging well you guys really
have balls I don't have the balls from
somebody else so this is an alternative
one but get you one of those you sure I
don't want to take your stuff oh thanks
but look you might only be able to do
the head the head
here I'll just take a it's a gummy gummy
bear yeah oh thanks is that too much
that's pretty yeah how many milligrams I
don't take the whole one so like you see
this one of the legs is the middle body
is that much and then the head's like
25. that's a lot I usually take 10 So
This is Gonna Knock me on my ass no
you're gonna have a good time with that
plus the flavor oh my God boy I'm
excited I like it you can't eat cilantro
you'll eat weed I definitely will jam
and that's why my house I had the
munchies so bad the other day it was so
high I had the munchies and my whole
my refrigerator everything is clean
because I want to I'm not doing
resolutions anymore but I decided I said
I want to start getting into a whole
food plant-based this and that so I'm
slowly like getting all the meat out of
my freezer mm-hmm so I'm just I've had
some chicken
um I made this beautiful uh like a strip
chicken right so I had a chicken breast
I seasoned up nice everything I baked it
the whole thing blah blah blah then I
had some collard greens I had some kale
I had spinach put that in there a little
bit of onions shredded up that chicken
put that and made a nice little stew put
some chicken broth in it so I've been
eating that so now as I move forward I'm
gonna try to get rid of the chicken of
it but then I can keep that sort of like
kind of Stew thing going so it's been
really great you know with the seasons
and all that so trying to do that is
something that you have to think about
yeah it has Comics sometimes we don't
have discipline no we just want to go on
stage we just want to make you laugh and
then everything else outside of that
world is dysfunctional as [__] and as
I'm getting older I'm like
wow I've been dysfunctional my entire
life
um you know comedians are very smart
um where we have the ability to be very
manipulative also right maybe not in a
bad way but in a way of you know
definitely trying to get those laughs
out with your your Vibe we can feel you
the whole thing and I just said as I'm
getting older I just want to not like I
have friends who wake up in the morning
and they're like oh I have a list of
checklist right right oh I did this um
this is this is I thought I said oh my
God I don't know how long my cats are
going to live now that they one of them
got to take pills all the time I'm like
I barely remember to take vitamins so
then I put like little notifications I
got my notification [__] now like damn
pills at this time pills at that time
you have to train that's how I lost my
cat actually is it you didn't take the
pills painkiller addiction he overdosed
Is that real no just kidding you know I
believe everything else for Sam so but
to dedicate yourself perfect
he was on perks as a cat pill joke you
know I'ma stop for a good joke man I
appreciate it thank you so the other
things everything we're saying is
sincere I do feel like a buddy you say
Comics are are manipulative but I
watched that the person dumped the mice
on his Gram I'm like I've never done
that no no no you didn't really get
these in person right okay in a negative
way like you know like some people are
manipulative like conniving and running
and stuff yeah I mean when we get on
stage obviously and that's why
um having so many years of practice not
that somebody can't be good right away
but taking being good and then also
adding years of practice to it you know
how to get into an audience you know
where okay there's little spot here let
me do this I know what you need over
here I know what you need there it's you
know is we we focus on those things so a
lot of times on the outside of your life
everything else could just be being held
together right I made it through school
I was smart it was easy I bullshitted my
way through everything I was able to be
on a on this list and all this other
[__] because just because I'm smart I
retain information right away but it
doesn't mean I was really like
a Collegiate student you know what I
mean like an intellectual like I just
bullshitted my way through that right I
think there's a lot of things that we
sort of as Comics sometimes we just
[__] we can we can make it through
this I can go to a party and be Charming
enough I'm not you know I may not
actually be an extrovert but I can go
there and be Charming
so now I want to be the person that like
really has a thing that I do outside of
Comedy all right I have my list
oh I'm gonna go to the farmer's market
right oh I'm worried about my health
bedtime like none of these things have I
ever had in my life to be a function and
the people who are my friends I grew up
with all have these functional lives and
a little bit of me wants like a look I
get that function but I agree and we're
getting older and we need to have [__]
like that and we need a little stability
because we're all wild horses running
around but you don't want to lose your
Edge either
that's true I mean that's true I don't
think you ever could
I don't know I'm maybe losing a little
bit of my Edge you know what you need to
do you got to get more pet mice
yeah that would be that would be good
yeah
this whole place would collapse if you
had pulled out a [__] wreck I'm
telling you I would I would disappear
um no you gotta but you find a different
um
you know what somebody said that I'm
supposed to be on um I'm sure this is
breaking news because not everybody
knows this I'm supposed to be on
antidepressants
you're supposed to be so yes I'm
supposed to be an antidepressant so I'm
gonna wait to get the antidepressants
because I really don't need I you know
she said I don't you know like I need
them but I'm like you know what I mean
let me just see so because I don't like
to pop pills no you know what I mean I
can do so anyway
um I was reading all these things about
the antidepressants that I'm gonna be on
and videos of people like oh this
changed my world my life and one of the
things like I'm saying was like well I
don't know if I want to be on the
antidepressants because I don't want to
lose
there's a little bit of a creep in me
you know like that creature that's there
that's like
up for anything yeah we say anything we
have fun and sometimes that does that
kind of edge can get people in trouble
right because except for anything you
say anything and then on the after you
go oh I didn't mean it like that I
should have said that or whatever but I
was just having fun you know you want to
find a way to quiet that just a little
bit or at least have that person that
little creep inside you think a little
bit Yeah and then maybe if we let him
think or her think or they think a
little bit maybe the thought would be a
little more developed oh you understand
because a lot of times people go oh no I
have no filter that's why it's so this
and that but it's like maybe if you put
a little bit of cap on that thing inside
you and it had time to really go deeper
into what he was thinking about maybe it
would come out with something even more
brilliant so I want to find those spaces
and I want to do that now because
people are getting older now and they
really killing it as they're getting
older yeah I'm following a lot of pages
of women and men in their 60s and 70s
they're not even slowing down 70s going
to school taking up a new hobby doing it
like it's 70 like back in the day when
you was 13 they was already like well
where you gonna get your plot because
you and your wife got to die yeah by the
time you're 21 nobody was living past 21
everybody get out here so it's just
those little things I want people to
think about like what do you as you get
older
where how do you want to see yourself
what do you want to see about what do
you want people to see about you what do
you want people to think about you love
about you and you start doing those
things I want people to be like you know
what yum she's very organized and you
know what she always has some little
thing this this this this
that's what I want that's a great that's
so funny we just had Tom Segura on a
little while ago he told us he gets up
at eight with a trainer he trains for an
hour then he plays piano then he plays
with his kids he wrote a book he does
stand up he does his podcast wow and he
tells he doesn't drink and I was like
holy [__] because we romanticize these
cocaine wild you know sex [__] comedy
doing the road getting crazy but there
is a price to it and you're right with
we're getting older but there's
something fun like what if Richard Pryor
said you know what I'm gonna go go
vegetarian and not drink maybe we
wouldn't have some of that fun we don't
get the freeway story he's dead yeah
but he you know I I think in my like I
still do my weed I have my moments yeah
I think we just want to have little mo
we don't want that to be no I'm with you
you know I play mahjong I take long hot
baths I listen to Joan Baez and that's
about it for me no no of course not I
drink and I'm a [__] loser what do
you want from me
you know what's so funny and and uh I'll
say this right so I I've been processing
a lot of stuff everything that I went
proud I always I personally was like
okay I don't want to deal with that I
just go whatever but I'm not gonna
process it so I was processing something
really heavy you saw it the night then I
know we talked about it yeah and thank
you for you just being a lovely person I
mean I don't wanna I I feel sad when I
see you sad so I will see you soon
because people are not used to seeing me
sad yeah and I would always I had a but
I had a bag of mice I was about to pour
on you and then I saw you look sad and I
was like another day I guess I mean
let's just save it but I never let
people see me say and I'll always just
be you know choo choo chewing through
that [__] no we usually are laughing
together but I saw you you there was a
heaviness I could tell you were upset it
was a prize
this isn't all about relationship but a
little bit of part of it was about
relationship and somebody said something
to me early in the day that made me
really sad and then I tried to like push
other [__] around it and put
when
um my mother was talking to me she says
oh you know what are you gonna is your
whole life gonna be comedy right you
know she want Grand kitchen what this is
that I said well you know listen
yeah my whole life since I was 16 has
been nothing my comedy then when I think
about it I go
for the amount of flack I get from
certain people about why I don't have
this relationship this is I've never had
a functioning a real functioning
relationship because I've never had a
relationship that didn't be the
convenience of being around comedy right
yeah so I'ma [__] some comic I'm gonna
deal with them full cup you know what I
mean I've never put myself out there to
be like oh there's a whole world of men
that have nothing to do with comedy
nothing to do with this world you saying
you regret what we had
I mean not until that fought
you know I got to rethink things all
right but don't continue so by the way
when you pursue Comics this is what you
get yes remember that you know when it's
easy it's just it's also yes but also
are you bored do you go out with
non-comics and you're just kind of bored
is that part of it too
I don't if a guy I have no I started
doing stand-up when I was 16. wow that's
all I missed my prom like I I went to
the first part of my prom and I had a
spot I had to go somewhere like I almost
missed my graduation like I wasn't
[__] around I was very dedicated once
I got into stand-up that I was doing
stand up so I didn't enjoy anything like
I don't really remember my 20s because
after that point everything was about
that so when I look and I see friends of
mine who are like some of them are
married to people they've known you know
Scotland sweethearts and this isn't that
I don't know I'm not if a guy tried to
uh other than try to [__] me like if a
guy tried to really be like hey you know
I'd be like what beat it I got [__] to
do and for women there is a thing where
you go I don't have the luxury to have a
family and kids and [__] right now
because that shit's gonna slow me down
that's why like a lot of times female
comments are like we get jealous of the
male Comics because you guys are gonna
have a wife and she's gonna be like
making bread and [__] zucchini fries and
[__] at home waiting for you to come
whisting in from the road and darling
and look at the kids that I'm here
tending to it's like if I had if I got
married and I had kids and I gotta
[__] worry about these kids people
like where the mama at and all this
other [__] and then I you know I I'm I
can't be you know I love to bake I love
to cook I love to do all those things I
can't do that all the time in a
relationship with a guy I can't beat a
woman that's like oh here's your
slippers even if I like to do those
things even if I like to take care of a
man I don't have the time
to do that [__] I mean I took off
December all of December so I'm not
going anywhere I work really really hard
then next thing you know I got booked on
four different things and I had to fly
out four different times in December it
was like crazy so it's like I don't know
and I can't be telling people and I
can't so it's all those things that sort
of come to a head right who are you
gonna be what you gonna be you know I'm
I'm sharing my own personal journey of
what I'm going through but I hope that
whoever's listening or whoever sees this
finds a correlation with where they are
and what they that everybody has to go
through these sort of things where you
kind of look up and you go
what have I done what am I going to do
sure and what do I think needs to be
changed in order to make sure that I
have happiness
you know because life gets short but
life also can be long as [__] if life
ain't short oh yeah it's well it's hard
to have it all I mean it's hard to have
the career and and I get it female
Comics you know you do have to make it
or entertainers or just women in that
yeah you know you do have to make a
choice and the clock is ticking it's
really uh it's unfair it's a bummer it's
only unfair when
um you could adopt a pet rat yeah that
would be pretty cool I could adopt
children anyway the thing about it is
when talking about fertility with women
is a dicey thing because there's some
women that's out here you know Janet
Jackson went had a baby at 50. you know
should you should you not I think the
only problem is fertility is a very
personal thing so I'm not it ain't like
I can't have no bait like and my [__]
ain't shut up you know what I mean I can
you know have a pop out a baby my the
window is obviously closing do I have
time in the next two or three years to
go ahead and pop this kid out probably
not unless I made some type of sacrifice
but at the same time I think women need
gentleness from men not to be saying
certain [__] to women as they get older
if we all could agree not to be [__]
on each other right and and men going
well you're not valuable you're not this
because you can't have a baby some women
don't want children some women can't
have no matter what age they're at true
putting uh these sort of like you got to
be a wife mother combo and a woman to
make a woman feel like she's a woman is
the same as telling a man he has to be
masculine or he has to be a father or a
provider of this and that it's like when
we start to get into these little dicey
areas that's where people start to have
their big issues on uh adjusting and I
was I was in the swing of that uh for a
long time as you get older you're not
adjusting to getting older well and I've
had people make me feel bad about
getting older and now I'm at the point
through
healing and looking and what I want and
also where I'm just like hey you know
what I'm such a
[__] Dominica okay it don't matter
how [__] old I am it doesn't matter
any under this stuff as long as I'm
being a good person or and not impeding
on other people's [__] and and doing the
best I can doesn't mean I'm not gonna
fail or have faults and just but as long
as I'm out here doing me that's all I
can do you know and that's all the
validation I need you know and I want to
make sure that I'm not for other people
and not tearing down other people in in
the ways that you know could be
destructive to them yeah being nice to
other people is such a big part of it I
mean like yeah you're viable you don't
have to have kids if everyone had kids
it would be [__] annoying try getting
on a flight to Orlando there's too many
[__] kids yeah oh facts I just said
that I said when I was flying jet blue
and they don't have a Sky Lounge I um
they gotta work on that but then they
just walk spirit so I don't think it's
getting any better yeah right all I saw
was families it's like where the [__]
you going as a family oh why would why
do you have to travel if you're a family
all the [__] you know is in your house
stay there who are you going to go meet
up with another family yeah even more of
a family somewhere and especially for I
never traveled I never went to
Disneyland my parents never took me
anywhere so I see these kids in business
class and I'm like what the [__] is this
oh my god there was a baby in first
class
I know that's two grand although I did
eat his meal but I hope so he took his
bottle
but uh no it's uh yeah I heard Spirit
doesn't even have a lounge they have a
Detention Center they throw you in
spirit ain't gosh [__] and I all I know
is uh families that travel as families
is the gayest thing out and and
everybody the lgbtq plus Community can
come for my crown on that stop traveling
as a [__] family no I just be a man
leave your kid behind come on
go get some cigarettes I just did South
America to to here 16-hour flight
there's I must have been in the nursery
Plus or whatever the [__] I was in
whatever section it was just cradles and
strollers and kids they were doing
crafts and cutting [__] up and making
hand turkeys it was brutal I was on
Gymboree air Mark's actually coughing a
new strain of covet on us as we speak I
wish I could I let me I gotta tell y'all
this so first of all I I always do this
joke about this little baby this first
class baby that was in first class
because I said I suck too much dick to
be in first class and this baby ain't
suck enough dick to be here
all babies need to be downstairs with
the pets in the cage because the kids
and animals love daytime together yes
Bill's character so let me take the
picture they won't remember the trip
anyway let me
they don't need the legroom I say the
same thing to garyveder get back there
[Music]
so I get on I already see a problem when
I go to sit down this is back in my
coach days
so I'm sitting there and I see a [__]
she got the baby the baby already doing
that stiff board [__] right where the
baby you know he ran and ran and you
know bipping and bopping to the side I
said oh no I said I hope this [__] is
not behind me so now and you know she
can't even get the little [__]
out of his jacket because he's up here
doing all this [__] so I said oh my God
I go to sit down
did we not even on takeoff like people
still he put I mean kicking you remember
when the kids uh now I know I'm a little
bit older than y'all but we still around
the same time when the parents would
take the shoes and they would dip the
shoes and [__] and put them as on the
bronzer yeah they were bronze them but
remember them big shoes he would wear as
a kid that had them hard bottoms but now
they put them on the kids that got um
cerebral palsy oh yeah because they're
one little cerebral palsy shoes with the
damn I don't know with the brace you
don't know the braids with the oh yeah
they were like black and white shoes but
now they only put them on the center
palsy kid shoes I remember that they
were clunky yeah they was cutting thick
and they had a bottom yeah put yeah put
it hard bottom wait a minute no put in
80s because
now put the 80s baby shoes because with
hard bottoms because I'm telling you
those and let me tell you something this
little [__] almost kicked my back out
he damn the shits right there yeah
that's it yeah them Forrest gumps
dim's the one yeah the Air Force get the
one with the soul look how thick the
soul is yes look at that thing now all
of that [__] it looked it looked like
wood is pure steel it's got more Soul
than Marvin Gaye oh my God the kid
almost can't make it past TSA with these
shoes
now this kid had these shoes on he was
kicking a hole I didn't even know that I
had a hole in my back I had to go to the
chiropractor after the flight he kept
kicking and kicking so I turned around
and I did the one little like you know
the girl she smile yes and she didn't
say nothing whatever so finally the kid
was tap tap tap dancing and we was in
the sky and I turned around and said hey
I said come on now like what's going on
with him
and the family next to me they had a
little kid and it was so sad because I
had gotten with this mother so hard that
the little kid that was sitting next to
me he was a angel cute little thing and
he want to fall asleep and he bit you
know he fell over on on me and the
mother was like like oh yeah yeah he's
fine I said no he's okay I said this one
is kids tap dancing on my back and the
mother whatever so then
after the flight was over I waited
because I was like now I want to talk to
her so when people come I sit in a turn
I said listen I said you have to do
something about this kid I said because
my whole flight was ruined nobody's
gonna get I said I don't deserve this
and I understand your mother says well
I'm traveling alone and his father blah
blah blah I said listen
if you can't take care of the baby and
the flight then maybe you should see if
maybe the pilot could take the baby
doing the flight or maybe the flight
attendance juggling the baby yeah you
got horrible turbulence with the pilot
put him in the windshield do something
but I want you to know that he is
incomplete inconvenience to my back
structure yes and I might have to go see
a chiropractor I said he was kicking a
lump in the bed and I said and you were
doing nothing about it and then she goes
what do you want me to do and then one
other woman comes in because you don't
know you must not have any kids you must
not know what it means to be a mother I
go here we go with this [__] again oh
boy oh cause I didn't oh I didn't have a
[__] slide through my [__]
birth canal I don't know what it means
to be a consideration I wish I was on
this flight so badly no I I got with him
[__] you [__] are you kid no because
these 400 Mothers Against Drunk Driving
or whoever the [__] they are I'm telling
you stay on the drunk driving [__] don't
come over here to the flagship because I
don't need don't not Mom shame me not
Mom shame me I'm with you and you got a
baby tap dancing like he's [__]
Lou Rawls on the back of my [__] back
the whole time [__] yeah I mean what if
I brought a crackhead on a plane and he
was just freaking everybody out and
drooling on people I would be yelled at
but what what's the difference with a
kid it's your responsibility it's not my
problem it's your kid you should yeah
it's the same with a dog you bring a dog
on the plane you gotta [__] it up
anymore I'm gonna bring a crackhead to
open there you go just so if someone's a
baby's room like my guy's more annoying
you know what happened to me recently I
was flying back New Year's Day from
Spokane Washington and you know three
Show New Year's night I'm [__] tired
three on New Year one of the crowds
stunk too the two were good one stop I'm
shocked he had that odd yeah exactly I
anyway the flight's delayed Vita is a
cycle he wants to get back to his kid I
have nothing to live for I take the
later flight out but Gary's Gary's at
the 6 a.m flight I take the noon it gets
delayed now I'm like I might be [__]
in my connection with the change I'm
already Landing like 11 I'm like they
say you might not make your connection
I'm in the air they say yeah this you're
not gonna make the connection we booked
you a hotel in Atlanta this is January
1st this is not how I want to start my
new year and I go hell [__] no
I'm making this connection yeah we land
in Atlanta I'm losing my [__] it was I
was having a pleasant conversation with
the guy next to me until this happened I
was just like someone do something I'm
losing it I'm texting my dad I'm like
Dad I I can't get through on the uh
customer service app can you just call
my dad's the best he calls for me says
don't take him off this like they move
me off the flight what yeah because
they're like you're not gonna make this
connection like I can make it I can
[__] make it right yeah you've never
seen me Sprint in my life
[__] weaving I'm like I was like
proud of my cardio yeah I'm not in good
shape I hope it wasn't Atlanta cause
that it was Atlanta
I get there by a [__] eyelash I get I
I'm sweating I'm drenching sweat so I
had to run so fast I didn't even take my
beanie off so I'm in a beanie
I sit down this is the most dirt bag
[__] I've ever done I sit down drench
and sweat I go whiskey soda yeah
[Applause]
yeah dirty move to do it that's not a
dirty move that's a real whiskey soda
here I love that I know but when you're
drenched in sweat it does feel gross but
I was like I need it put me in a better
mood immediately yes and I after that
second I got the drink I'm texting my
dad I was like I love you you're the
best wow
you're a good man good man that little
knickknack [__] they love that yeah damn
my dad would go who's this
well that's my other dad
that's the bio dad but the kid thing
they should have a thing called family
air let all the families fly you guys
bring all your kids bring all your
toddlers all your uh unwanted children
that you had on here we're gonna get
hate for this well what would you get
hateful because there was a New York
Times article about this recently and it
was basically saying no Kids In First
Class kids should not be allowed there
and it got so much [__] smoke you
pull it up really okay I read the
comments and they were like [__] this
[__] like but people don't complain
because their parent [__] them listen I
grew up in the 80s in a different time
we listen my mother you had rules and
regulations it's like listen we're going
to go you're gonna get in the car you're
not going to wall out sit down be quiet
don't open your mouth unless now people
got parents doing any uh doing whatever
they want yeah I agree I think if you're
a parent just [__] parent if your
kids being outrageous give the look
around just be like sorry that's all I
need do or do something that's all
because I'm with you with the crackhead
thing you're not wrong thank you yeah I
think that my parents don't like to be
told to be picked that's where they get
an attitude about the parenting because
they're like well you don't know because
someone so and so and Skippy got this
going on and Skippy got through it and
we're doing something different with him
that in my childhood we didn't do this
and do that I'm like listen if you know
your child has some type of issues or
problems or something you can't get a
handle on and you ain't got access to
Super Nanny keep your ass at home yeah
yeah I do like the birth canal line the
best so that you said on the flight I
say that a lot because I have a lot of
most of the women I know are mothers and
they they think they they think they've
elevated above me like I'm not a common
sense person that I couldn't listen
[__] all it takes is Dick to come
inside your vagina for you and you to
ovulate and get the [__] popping and
percolating for you to become a mother
you didn't get any type of damn degrees
for that yeah anyone can do it anybody
actually [__] [__] can be a dad
anybody can [__] be a parent yes okay
but what I'm telling you is stop getting
an attitude when I'm telling you that
your child is getting on my [__]
nerves because I don't think they
understand how how much people are
taking into consideration that we don't
want to say you know some people just
[__] they hate kids but for me I'm
not just trying to wall out on you I'm
gonna give you that Grace yeah I like
kids I don't want to like make the kid
feel some kind of [__] [__] way
but after a while [__] your kid has
stomped a mud hole in my back and you
act like you don't know that it's there
right exactly just give me a little
courtesy and I I get it if a kid's
crying you know what are you gonna do
that's it the kid's gotta cry but just
give it a little sorry sorry mud hole in
my back sounds like a great Blues album
I got a mud hole
cause a toddler stomped it out
that's a tough one and you want to take
a good on vacation that's a hell of a
peeve yeah that's a great fall back down
and said first class doesn't promise
relax say oh come on oh that's the whole
point that's the whole point he has
[__] come on kill the kids kill them
all yeah abortion I bet I haven't seen
no kids oh you know what that's the LIE
my Delta one
flight going to La it was
um kids but I'm thinking of I think the
kids were sitting with the no not the
ones Delta one is too nice for kids uh
they have it don't don't the ones
[__] nice super nice it's crazy oh
yeah no it's super nice they but they
did have it for the kids each kid sat
with a parent and then they knew the
other kids that was sitting three back
it was crazy and one of them was I
thought I said oh God they gonna get
started because one of them was like I
want to sit with him and get and they
was like we wait till everything and
they're like no I'm almost screaming but
then I love the fathers that that are
really fathers that you go my happiest
moment was when I saw this white man fan
his little girl's legs in the grocery
store it was so crazy what he fanned
them little legs that's why grandma say
fan of legs we go like that okay so he
she go she tore something down and he
said don't do it and she took a magazine
this little girl was bold and she
ripped that back down
and all he said he said okay we have to
pay for this now she goes no she didn't
want him to pay for it and he said I
what did I say and he popped them little
legs I said who the hell is this black
woman living inside this white man's
body I had never seen a white man pop
his kid before didn't they try they
tried to Freaky Friday with that didn't
they did they did they it was like Tracy
Morgan maybe oh I'm surprised that flew
foreign
and kids were seen and not heard like we
sat at the kids table when we got out
there there was a section for us right
everybody had their place and yeah and
you got quiet and you didn't open your
mouth you wouldn't dare you wouldn't
dare say something up get dude so and so
if I told my grandmother no my all my
lips and everything would be sitting on
the floor
you don't say no oh yeah my dad when he
came home it was over he's just pulled
in the driveway it was like battle
station but there's got to be a little
bit of a that seems so nice that's crazy
it's nice now he's on antidepressants he
lost his Edge
true story yeah can't get it up damn you
see it real hard when he beat you right
oh yeah that's what he beat me with now
and and see what they don't understand
is nobody's condoning uh uh abusing
children there's got to be a good happy
medium I think some of the [__] in the
80s was rough oh yeah kind of crazy you
know what I mean yeah and I'm not here
the thing that breaks my heart is when I
see
um and I see this a lot up you know in
Harlem no disrespect you know because a
lot of times when it's an area with his
children and the mothers are raising the
kids by themselves they're going through
stuff they're young and also [__] they
don't have to haven't learned the
patience yet but it just it bothers my
spirit to hear a mother go come on
[__] some [__] like that
you know because it's like oh wow like
the kid
I canceled all the time but they don't
pay me notice don't speak human but you
can say the N word to it yeah oh all the
time but my cats love me and the whole
thing but you know but it just to I
understand like breaking down nobody's
here to say break down a child's spirit
we have to be very careful how we talk
to Children yes you want to reinforce
certain things in the children but you
also you cannot be scared to tell the
child that there are boundaries some
parents just want their kids to live
boundary free right I don't want to
impede on his growth no you have to
teach him or her or them that they are
in an environment where other people are
also moving around in space and time we
live in a society yeah we live in a
[__] society
Anika it's gonna catch up later when
they're at a job and they're going why
isn't everything going my way blah blah
blah it's just it's just be kind your
neighbor too it's just basic [__] just
be we're in a shared space right now I
don't give a [__] what you do at home
hopefully you don't hit your kids but
like when you're in a when you're in a
shared space be respectful to other
people yes common courtesy
you heard it here first folks yum are
you gonna be anywhere on the road any
anything coming up I'm taping to the
Bottom Road I'm supposed to say say it
say it
just in case uh oh look at that oh they
got better pictures of me now because oh
you're on life and Beth you're great on
it by the way life and death on Hulu
well we start taping you know I heard I
heard yeah I don't know if it's in the
streets but yeah we start taping down
south you was in it
yeah I got cut out but yeah I was in it
he was in it how did you get cut out I
saw you in it I'm a horrible actor no no
I did see you in it I don't think so you
must have been in it unless I was
looking at some early [__] maybe they
left me in I looked like I I didn't see
me in well this is awkward I got tagged
in it a lot I was a Carney
oh that's fun oh yeah we're doing season
two of that
uh-oh yeah get look you got a hell of an
Adam's apple hey it's a problem you do I
want to bite it's like such a Adam's
Apple gays are all over my ATMs oh yeah
I want to rub that finger up and down
right crazy I could do a cameo of me
just swallowing going up and down and
I'd get some big bucks they want to
picture their load going down that
gullet
lactic acid I had to get mine shaved
down there yeah oh what what
I didn't want to let that go you're a
[__] you're picturing it you got a
seagull right I could never transitions
this is uh but yeah we got uh we got
that going on and then you know I got my
live with yamika I do every Wednesday on
YouTube it's on Hiatus right now but you
know we'll keep that going up and
anytime you take my name in if Miss Pat
don't come up I'm the other one
um yeah you know we just having a good
time I taped something I I can't talk
about I tell you something really
spectacular I can't wait to see it
supposed to come out in in a couple
months oh boy and it's top secret
hopefully I didn't get cut out of this
[__] but they gonna have to do a lot of
work to cut me out of it because I was
everywhere all right but um I'm really
excited about it so if you guys are
listening around a certain you know area
yeah let me know and then they put my
[__] age there ah cut that out nah
it's nothing okay I signed up for
classmates.com when it first came out so
all my information is outdated we didn't
know it was going to come following us
20 years yeah right well check out yam
in the new raccoon video coming out it's
gonna be big and uh she's all over the
road you can see at the comedy seller
all the time any road dates you want to
plug
um
me Dan Pearlman and Kerry
yeah February the 16th uh I'm also doing
sketch Fest
in San Francisco so something in San
Francisco I never put my dates up so
they going out to that is the wrong move
but
um thank you for this time you know what
I really appreciate I never have wanted
to there's maybe a few podcasts I
believe I really wanted to sit down with
you guys thank you for having me what we
want to do for a long time I think we
tried you for a long time
but I'm just I'm so glad this feels
perfect now so and I thank everybody for
listening so thank you thank you for
coming on I will be I guess this is the
next week right so I'll be in uh
I'll be in uh Vegas Vancouver Seattle uh
Portland uh keep adding shows are Salt
Lake we're adding shows uh Atlantic City
added a show of Royal Oak added Show
Minneapolis added show keep going down a
lot of fun stuff uh Madison Milwaukee
Milwaukee moving slowly New Haven Boston
we keep adding shows Miami Orlando Ponte
Verda beach near Jacksonville Atlanta
Charleston Durham Charlottesville
Norfolk DC uh added a show Wilkes bar
not adding the show Portchester new
yorksameral.com shows more add-ons
coming I love you guys I'm gonna try to
go off book here Hawaii Miami Spokane
Appleton uh about but uh yeah doing some
stuff with uh Bert in Phoenix special
coming oh yeah we got a taping cooking
just the taping special be way down the
line gotta edit but uh Rochester
uh laugh it up you name it
marknormancomedy.com do you know where
you're taping the special I do where
can you say it
I guess I can why not where'd you tape
yours Chicago all right yes different
venue I'm giving too much okay I'm sorry
all right I've been trying to get people
excited it's at the Vic all right okay
great room all right all right and get
Bodega cat get a t-shirt get some
sweaters get a hat and uh yeah we'll see
you all in Hell love you guys no no
praise Allah Kevin Evan I don't see you
in heaven
[Music]
and I get down in the same way
dangerous
[Music]
I'm out to lunch here in New Orleans
this woman doesn't look like I remember
her and I get down in the same way
we might be true
[Music]